MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Hi.
I'm Maya Kaczorowski.
I'm here at KubeCon
in Copenhagen.
And I'm here with Craig
Peters from JFrog.
How are you?
CRAIG PETERS: I'm doing great.
How about yourself?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Great.
So tell me a little bit
about what JFrog does.
CRAIG PETERS: Sure.
So JFrog is a repository
manager and platform
for enabling software developers
to collaborate effectively
across distributed teams with
all the different package
types they use, all the
different tools, and do
it in a way that's safe and
allows software to be delivered
faster to any endpoint.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: What do you
mean by a way that's safe?
How does that work
with containers?
CRAIG PETERS: Oh, well that's
a really great question.
I'm so glad you asked.
[LAUGHTER]
It's as though we staged
or practiced this.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
And yet we didn't.
CRAIG PETERS: Absolutely not.
So what I mean by safe is that
when you deploy an application
into any environment-- so let's
take Kubernetes as an example--
why would we be talking
about that here?
But if you're deploying
to Kubernetes,
you might have packaged
your application in Helm.
So you might have Helm
charts that you're using
to deploy the application.
Those depends on
Docker images, right?
Those Docker images,
you know where they are.
They're in some sort
of secure registry.
How do you know what's
in those containers?
So what JFrog
artifactory provides,
we call it the
Kubernetes registry.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Oh, I see.
CRAIG PETERS: The
Kubernetes registry
of artifactory allows you
to have, in one place,
the source of truth
for all of the data,
all of the package types,
all of the dependencies
that have been built
into the container image,
and then packaged
into a Helm chart
and used to deploy
the application.
You can use any
other packaging type.
It doesn't depend on Helm.
But essentially, we act
as a Docker registry
that understands
all the dependencies
so you know where things are.
And then as a repository
manager, what that means
is that you can create different
repos for different teams
at different stages of
a development lifecycle.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: So if I have
a different one for my app
testing you know--
CRAIG PETERS: Exactly.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Got it.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: OK.
CRAIG PETERS: Dev,
QA, production.
So production can only read
from production repositories.
And then you don't want to
duplicate all those things.
We essentially have
a promotion model.
So based on-- you
might want to make it--
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: You
move it from one registry
to another or
something like that?
CRAIG PETERS: Exactly.
Automatically.
And you want to make so only
service accounts can do that.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Got it.
CRAIG PETERS: And
then you want to make
that completely independent
of the underlying storage
and use any off mechanism.
That's what we do.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
And do you want
to talk me through what's
happening right here?
CRAIG PETERS: Absolutely.
So the story here is that you're
deploying an application that's
packaged as Docker Images inside
a Helm chart to Kubernetes.
Well, what's in it?
It's Docker Images.
If you look at an image, it
actually is usually layers--
we use layering
and all of that--
that consists of
your application,
whatever code you've written--
maybe it's Maven.
You might have written
Java and used a build tool,
or it might be npm.
And you've got that bit.
You've got the packages
you've depended upon,
which are external
packages, and you
might have operating systems.
So the idea, from
left to right, is
that using a common registry
framework, you can manage--
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: All
of the dependencies.
CRAIG PETERS: Exactly-- all
the way to the lowest level.
And that's actually really
important for companies
where the software production
pipeline is their production.
And you can't be
blocked if you have
an issue getting to the public
npm, for example, right?
And that stops
people, in reality.
And so what we do
is, we create what's
called a virtual
repository that sits
on top of your local repo
and the remoted repos
that you have a local cache of.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Got it.
CRAIG PETERS: And that
allows organizations
to have really good
control over what packages
go into their applications.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: And so tell
me about Grafeas and how-- or,
sorry-- tell me how
JFrog works with Grafeas.
So Grafeas is Google's open
source metadata image server.
And you were one of
the launch partners
for that back in October.
How does that work together?
CRAIG PETERS: Absolutely.
So one of the things you have
to do in this kind of a scenario
is, you have to have a
really deep understanding
of the metadata about all of
the different package types.
Grafeas is an open API
for exchanging metadata
about those assets between
many different systems.
A lot of different
tools in the ecosystem
will generate different kinds
of information about those.
So the first things we
started with, obviously,
are vulnerabilities.
Everybody wants
security and safety.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Yes.
Security!
CRAIG PETERS: Yeah.
So one of our products
is called Xray.
And Xray is a part
of this package.
And what it does is, it
has a deep understanding
of the layered packaging.
It unpacks them all,
understands the components
that go into a package, matches
them against vulnerabilities.
But we also do licenses
and other things like that.
The point of Grafeas
is that it makes
it very easy and lightweight to
exchange information between us
and other Grafeas
data providers.
So say Google has
a huge database
of different kinds of data,
like maybe performance
or compatibility data.
You need a way to aggregate
that in your CI pipeline
so that you can make automated
decisions about whether or not
your software is ready to move
from staging into production.
And so you don't want
to have to go and query
all of the different systems.
Xray provides a way,
using Grafeas to aggregate
all of that data into--
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
A single place.
CRAIG PETERS: --one call.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Makes sense.
Great.
Well, thank you so much
for chatting with us
on the floor at KubeCon.
CRAIG PETERS: I'm
really glad to.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Having a good time here?
CRAIG PETERS: Oh,
it's been great.
We've had lots of
great conversations.
And we're really glad to
be here and participating
in this community.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Thank you so much.
Hopefully we'll
see you in Seattle.
CRAIG PETERS: Absolutely.
[INAUDIBLE]
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: And thank you
all for joining and watching us
here at KubeCon.
CRAIG PETERS: Thank you, guys.